now I know your orbit future what comes
next but what I've noticed on your
Instagram you you do kind of look back a
bit well I mean sometimes because shapes
me yeah
Oh sometimes I feel nostalgic okay no
lots of amazing people were in my life
tell me where exist yeah but a picture
you posted this what age are you here
five or six yeah that's a talent show
that was the beginning of my career as a
performing artist did you win I did not
I'd love to know who won
she died under mysterious circumstances
it was a terrible playground accident
we've got some more pictures this must
mean I think when you I think this is
just you hanging out in a club with
Diana Ross Rodgers jelly bean there
[Applause]
I'll just do that yeah there you go yeah
and I'm wearing a skirt that keith
haring designed for me Oh what about
that's the best part of the picture
yeah and would you just hang out like
that then oh yeah yeah yeah do you miss
that oh yeah I was hanging out with
artists is that why Lisbon was so kind
of amazing that you'd get to do that
yeah this must be this is early early
days but you were I mean with the
Beastie Boys that's Madison Square
Garden Wow and that's when they pulled
my pants off of me
after green skirt and then we had a
water gun fight on stage they were my
opening act this was because the fans
didn't know the Beastie Boys they helped
nobody had ever heard of them and
everyone said that I was gonna be booed
off the stage where they weren't even be
brewed off the stage or what was I
thinking and I'm crazy and nobody knows
them and their music is crap and all
that stuff and I said yes they're
opening up for me
[Music]